noch neun spieler von bittet rater das
ist so unfair man ja alle potter darf
mich alter ich wenn alle trader von drei
tätern verfolgt allerdings mit fein auf
mich und hier nein nein nein
jo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde mafia und so wie gestern
oder vorgestern das was man noch nicht
ich halte der mojang dabei und ich hab
zum ohrwurm von diesem einen film wie
heißt der world of wall street der wall
street
ich muss auch nicht ich habe nie auf
dieser map keine ahnung ich möchte
unbedingt in der jazz programm ändert es
gibt ja auch wichtig ist hier oben
nichts man das ist doch super so
exponiert hier muss was geben
etwas das wirklich nicht gar nicht
zweimal für die sparkasse ich will jetzt
ein schwert haben bitte und konnte mich
wieder ansteigen
ich habe ein schwert du wirst du weiß
ich wer bist du bist du weißt du sagt
matthias vfl schwerte ein schwert der
kommissar wird für heimlich räumlich ich
träume nicht alle das ist schon beinahe
alle ewald trade etwas traurig traurig
traurig
nein noch neun spieler von bittet rater
das ist so unfair man ja alle pole doch
mich alter ich wenn alle trader von drei
tätern verfolgt mit einer schifffahrt
auf mich nein nein nein wehrt diesen
aber auch richtig dumm diesem viel zeit
um mich zu fahren ich hab gar nichts
ich habe ein pfeil und zwei sticks wo
gott was die taktik
jetzt erst recht keine kiste überhaupt
irgendwo noch eine kiste normaler domino
jojo ich hab' ich hab sechs kommt mir
nicht so nah kommt mir nicht so nah
leuten wirklich abstand was mit diesen
ewigen später zufällig jean marie le pen
schwer hat alter und bogen und pfeile
auch ich bin im himmel und russischen
tor
ich lebe mein leben und ich hab so
brains okay sagt ja was der ist auf ihr
fahrrad den agenten eisenstädter war
ganz klar nein mein letzter zeit
verloren nein eher wie sowieso ist doch
egal sein die direkt ins leben oder wenn
es aber keine erinnerung ergibt ist
müssen wirklich in das überleben hängt
ja der händel aber immer gerne mal
scheiße mich zu verunsichern
die ganze zeitung der welt drauf ein
recht naiv
du bist nicht mehr du bist bisschen
alter komm her dann leise
er kann ich mal schießen kann feiern mit
der tagfalter ich hab gar nicht mehr so
viele leben dafür hoch
ich weiß nicht juni soll das waschen
oder gibt es mir feuerschutz ich
schreibe immer johnny gebt mir
feuerschutz branche hoffe ich kenne das
wort raschen hinterher
du bist ein killer
das alter wo gold altar erst richtig gut
man ist hier richtig gut das tut mir
leid
nein das war wirklich dumm angestellt
ach du scheiße ja gut leute gemeint
kurzen vielleicht wieder leute dass wir
wieder er hat gerade eben mojang gehört
wie ihr
grund sei dass man sich immer dass ich
hab mal geschafft
ich habe es auch geschafft ist das schön
premiere dippel der drei jahren
monatlich sagt sagt welche sachen für
mich dass ich der mannschaft ich habe
recht nein nicht im boden balken wo gott
die kiste holen können
du hund nicht verteidigen nur ein
viertel stack
gehen sie zu viel respekt
denn schön
und ich hab sogar ein stein schwert alte
beste leben ja ich bin der echte die
leute wollen mich bedeutet nicht so
nicht so fällt das mit irgendeiner faken
würde
ganz ehrlich ich bin nicht ungespült
oder so
naja vielleicht weniger ist auch dass
die ganze zeit als wiener aids gestorben
das mag ich nicht vom sterben hier
spieler bei den spielen können wir nicht
alle in frieden miteinander leben in
eintracht frankfurt jacob mark webber
clip nägel machen so mtv krebs und jeden
jeden der hoch kommt hinkel ich das mach
ich jetzt ob man gleich klar kommt nicht
hoch oder ich kenne euch ich sagte kommt
nicht hochkommen
er kommt doch und er muss darum gehen
was für ein spaß einfach unbewaffnet auf
mich zu und denke ich auch
egal noch ein mafioso ich komme ich auf
mein leben ich komme nicht auf mein
leben klar was da los
die kleine die kleine meiner musik heißt
die heißt das ja von johann sebastian s
k
nein nein nein
diese hunde soll der film wall street
gesehen habt euch ob ich den film
gefallen hat also ich wirklich alle
meine freunde bekannte bekannt bevor das
jetzt so hat er skaliert mit alkohol